welcome to this video playing the Blitz
kicker FM blitz kicker from the
Netherlands I want to see playing okay
we have a a new zone yeah this is my
preferred line against this opening but
Knight f3 after that I am playing I
think this one and I tend to forget the
lines so need to be a bit careful
playing this intermediate move on the
Queen the Queen c2 now is the normal
continuation the negev Bishop e7 we go
from there y term has a bad bone
structure but he enjoys a very good
bishop on g2 of course with pressure on
b7 yeah here's a situation where i can
give up the porn if i want i'm not sure
if i do it right away ya think I think
you just castle him and I'm forgetting
my my own my own book recommendation him
as it happens quite often um Queen a
five maybe mm or just move the night 96
yeah he can take on b7 but I don't fear
that very much maybe maybe this movie
now a six Quincy seven
Bishop d7 rugby aid is not not very
dangerous yeah from a structural point
of view like is an excellent shape but
the bishop on yeah this Bishop is
dangerous peas and white might get
activity with fy5 and stuff okay a5i go
95 that that much is clear should i do
these six d6f five not if I don't know
hmm maybe I should should really play
that sometime so that I have b6 Bishop
d7 available after f5 I can play Knight
e5 and I rather have this the structure
with the pawn or d7000 e6 so that e-cigs
is not weakened now it looks hairy okay
maybe hmm as to see have some move maybe
if he moves the night of the d4 Knight
somewhere he can play with Bishop v6m
maybe maybe I should have played Bishop
c5 really this is this is probably not a
bad idea controlling controlling
important squares and making it may be
difficult for him to move the night can
go to see two but not sure how how good
this is okay so
now what about is e five rotten mafia ii
five if he takes I should really Mike
Scott t5 but I also got a very nice
night on e five then complicated if he
takes Knight eggs not sure maybe maybe a
preferable first prep for you five
if i take that Quincy five then if five
isn't this quite ok text eggs can play
rugby three maybe but I also can just
play Bishop d7 yeah some cyber a simple
solution a simple solution preparing
Bishop c6 which is also very desirable
bishops is six now or first taking maybe
also relocate the night it still runs
into a check if i take it will be with a
check on c5 and a half night f5 may be
coming ok the light is good on f5 yeah I
like this this is a good position i
believe night f5 i can also play a five
now not sure about that but i don't have
so much time
yeah it looks weird huh it takes Quint
eggs with check it looks very very good
for black check it's also Bishop f5
after e3 for example to take on one see
20 Bishop c6 which is also definitely a
good move not sure what's better ship g4
also also not bad or bishop e6 attacking
see form let's maybe they're the easiest
smooth he's got queen before maybe queen
before as a defense hmm I didn't think
about that one
maybe I should have
yes stupid to not think about the movie
time warning just have given him this
move him almost for free it's not i'm
not in a bed in a bad situation but but
I would have I think I had some
something better probably the idea is
that he's a little bit overloaded with
the night and those pins Joe the most
problematic thing is the time actually
as it is so often position is pretty
good to put it mildly I think I'm
winning material now some porn is going
to going to get lost now at least some
point if not to see takes bishop reform
if it takes here I can take only 3 and
the rook is attacked and there was 94 so
before or capture maybe just capture him
oh just this I'm why resign the Sun
taking yeah I think it was a pretty good
position really here around here because
I had somehow soaked up the the early
pressure on the queenside and summer
whites pieces didn't work together to
well I really don't know if I played it
in the best way possible though but it
was okay i believe up to up to here
certainly but i'm not sure that he
played the best one and i'm curious
about that I went to Bishop to e6 yeah
the best seems to be Bishop f5 him yeah
you probably should go with her the
first instinct more often what I didn't
really see is that if he plays rookie to
now which looks like he really must do
that I should probably think very I
should think about this move here using
this awkward situation with the pin and
the B file
yeah this looks pretty good for black I
have some ideas here also with taking
and maybe night at five later yeah this
list looks fine the whole line is not
believed to be very good for light to be
honest this is this whole business here
but I'm I of course I have forgotten it
forgotten some lines maybe Queen c7 is
even better yet possible but I felt I I
was ok him f4 is a is a debatable move
it it covers a five and it certainly has
a point but it also weakens quite
considerably around here certainly have
a good position here in the immediate if
five also was interesting yeah computer
gives black good position here yeah I
wasn't I wasn't totally sure especially
considering that d 6 is a good
preparation move for 45 and he really
has no one great idea to to avoid it
anyway it seems that this wasn't so
right Andy five was more precise
probably due to this idea which I didn't
I didn't seem I only saw it a later turn
around here like a certainty okay yeah
the problem is white has a really really
bad structure and he didn't get any
great pressure here combined pressure of
the bishop and the bee phone so at the
end the better structure really was a
was paying off okay thanks for watching